- Welcome to the 22nd
annual John W. Hall lecture
in Japanese studies.
My name is Hwansoo Kim chair
of the Council in East Asian Studies.
Last year, due to the pandemic
we had to postpone this event.
And it seems like we
may be at the tail end
of this pandemic and
I'm extremely delighted
that we are able to host
this event in person today.
For those of you who are not familiar
with this lecture series,
I'd like to say a few
words about its background.
The John W. Hall lecture
series in Japanese studies
was established with general
support from Mrs. Robin Hall
in memory of her husband,
considered one of these past
century's finest scholars
of the history of Japan,
John Whitney Hall was
born in Tokyo in 1916
and developed an interest
in Japanese language,
culture and history at an early
age, after receiving his PhD
in east Asian and languages
and literatures at Harvard,
Hall began his academic career
at the University of Michigan
in 1949 and came to Yale in
1961 as a Whitney Griswold
professor of history,
a position he held until
his retirement in 1983.
Professor Hall specialized in
the through late Toga periods
and throughout his career,
he wrote or edited some
of the most important
and influential volumes
on Japanese history.
He contributed to the study of Japan
through not only his writing,
but also through service as chair
of several local and national committees.
Now I'd like to give the
podium over to Daniel Botsman
for introducing the speaker for today.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Professor Kim.
It truly is a delight to
be in person with you all.
And it is such an honor
to be able to introduce
and welcome back to Yale
Professor Noriko Mizuta,
a scholar who throughout
her career has given so much
to the fields of comparative literature,
Japanese literature, Japanese
studies, and women's studies
and whom in so many ways,
personifies the best
possibilities of the new forms
of intellectual exchange and
transnational scholarship
that were developed
between Japan and the U.S
in the second half of the 20th century.
Before saying more
about professor Mizuta's
remarkable career and scholarship,
I hope she'll forgive me
if I pause just briefly
to say a few words about
several other special guests
who we have here with us today
because of her.
So first, we're so grateful
to be able to welcome
two of professor Mizuta, five children,
Professor Akira Lipper,
would you mind standing up?
(audience applauding)
Is a leading scholar of
cinema and media studies
at University of Southern California,
which I'm sure you know,
has a pretty good media
studies in cinema program.
He is also vice Dean of the faculty
in the school of cinematic arts there.
And he's written about
everything from electric animals
to Jacque Deda and David
Lynch, one of my favorites,
and he's currently working on
a book about Japanese cinema,
which I'm sure we will all
learn a great deal from.
Professor Yuki Lipid is one of the world's
leading scholars of Japanese art history
at Harvard university,
like his big brother.
Kio and I we're in
graduate school together.
So I feel like it's okay
to use the familiar.
But Kio's work too is
extremely wide ranging.
But I will note in
particular that his book
on the Connell school of
painters from the early
Tokugawa period, in fact won
the John Whitney Hall prize
for the best book in Japanese studies
in the year that it was published.
And that was of course
awarded by the association
for Asian studies to another
John Whitney Hall connection.
We're also deeply honored to
be joined by Melissa McCormack,
who is the Andrew W. Mellon
professor of Japanese art
and culture at Harvard,
who many of you will know
through her brilliant
work on the interplay of
history, text and image
in medieval Japanese scrolls
and on the various forms
of artistic production
associated with the tale of Genji
and who studies of female
readers, writers and artists,
I think very much speak to questions close
to Professor Mizuta's heart.
Finally I wanna express
my deep, deep gratitude
to professor Alyssa Friedman.
Who's up in the back.
(audience applauding)
Who is professor of Japanese literature,
cultural studies and gender
at the University of Oregon.
Many of you, including the students
in the Tokyo seminar that
I'm co-teaching this semester
with Dr. Michael Thornton,
already know what an important
scholar Professor Friedman is
from her wonderful books,
including Tokyo in Transit,
and most recently Japan on American TV,
but she's also editor in
chief of the U.S Japan
women's journal,
which professor Mizuta
played a central role
in helping to found in the 1980s.
And a few years ago,
when I mentioned to professor
Friedman that I was teaching
undergraduate seminar
about Yale and Japan,
she asked me if I knew about
Mizuta census 2004 book
(indistinct), encountering
women's studies,
which included an account
of her experiences
as a graduate student
at Yale in the 1960s.
I'm afraid to say that I had
not known about that book
prior to that this conversation,
but I was so delighted to learn about it.
And I mentioned to Dr. Botel,
who had recently completed
his PhD in history here
that this wonderful book existed
and it would be so nice to
have a section of it in English
to be able to assign to Yale students.
And he said, "Well I'll translate it."
And so with professor Friedman's
support and encouragement,
he was able to publish it appropriately.
I think in the U.S Japan women's journal.
And those of you who've
had a chance to read that
translation or perhaps
the original or perhaps
professor Friedman's
fascinating bio critical essay
in the 2018 special issue of the review of
Japanese culture and society,
that was dedicated to
professor Mizuta's achievements
will know that she came to Yale from Japan
as a Fulbright scholar in 1961.
She was one of the first group
of students to actually fly
across the Pacific, to
come to the United States.
And that 1961 of course was
the same year that John W. Hall
moved here from the
University of Michigan.
So there's a nice connection
there too, I think.
A graduate of Tokyo Women's
Christian University,
Tokyo, (indistinct) Mizuta's
original plan at Yale
was to focus her studies
on William Forkner.
But her advisor here suggested
that perhaps she should think
about a different topic
and she ended up writing
her doctoral dissertation
about Edgar Allen Poe.
I actually went today to
manuscripts and archives
to try and retrieve a
copy so I could hold it up
and embarrass you,
but they wouldn't let me
take it out of the library.
So I'm sorry, but it
is here in the library.
And she later published a
book about based on that
dissertation in Japanese, under
the title of Edgar Allen Poe
after completing her
studies at Yale in 1970,
professor Mizuta hired
as an assistant professor
of American literature at
Marymont College in New York,
which is now part of Fordham University.
And I think that's a pretty
amazing thing in itself
that someone who had arrived from Japan
just a few years earlier,
was appointed as a professor
of American literature
at an American university.
She, after several years there
moved to take up positions
at Scripps college and eventually
the University of Southern California.
During this period, she also
became increasingly conscious
of the ways in which
gender, nation and race
continued to structure and
limit the study of literature
in the United States.
And she said about trying to change that,
particularly after her move to California,
she became centrally involved
in the establishment of
women's studies programs
that would help address the
exclusion of women from
mainstream academic research.
And she also would later
play an important role in the
establishment of women's
studies programs in Japan
and was involved among
other things in the creation
of the pioneering journal Feministo.
She also in the workplace
became involved in ethics
to advocate for basic
rights for female academics,
drawing attention to the many
disadvantages and problems
they continued to face in the U.S academy
and with her friend and
fellow Yale, PhD Kioko Selden,
she also began translating the work of
Japanese women writers,
which had previously
beaten largely inaccessible
to English language audiences.
This collaboration with Selden
would eventually lead to
multiple volumes of translated work,
which have now served as an
incredibly rich source of
inspiration for multiple
generations of students.
My personal favorite is still
professor Mizuta's translation
of (indistinct) smile of a mountain witch,
from the original collection,
which was published in 1982.
But I suspect many of you will have others
that have remained in your memories.
Through all of this of course,
professor Mizuta also continued to produce
her own scholarship,
including her 1982 book
reality and fiction
in modern Japanese literature,
which begins with the discussion
of the prewar eye novels.
And then after exploring
the work of (indistinct),
it concludes by showing
how (indistinct) work
really served to transcend
the limitations of
the prewar eye novel in large part,
because she was able to
draw in aspects of her own
experience as a woman
and as a woman writer.
Like John W. Hall,
she has also had a remarkable
career as an institution
builder in the middle of the 1980s,
she returned to Japan to
become vice chancellor
of the Josiah university
educational corporation
and threw herself into
the work of establishing
the Josiah international university,
which she became president of in 1996.
Again, as part of her
efforts to build this
dynamic new institution,
she created opportunities for
female scholars and leaders.
And although her own development
as a scholar was something
that emerged in the context of
post-war U.S Japan relations,
she has since built on that
foundation to establish truly
global connections, both
throughout Asia and to Europe.
Even as she has held these important
and demanding positions,
she has also continued to
publish volumes over her own
poetry and literary criticism
and Japanese on writers,
including Sylvia PLA, Doris
Lessing, Orinoco SU Yuko,
and (indistinct) among
others and on topics,
including feminism
patriarchy in the family.
In all of these ways and many others
that I have to admit today,
professor Muzita offers us a
model for how to build a truly
generative scholarly career
that opens new intellectual
worlds while also creating
opportunities for others.
With regard to Japanese
women writers in particular,
I would like to believe
that the recent attention
that authors, including
(indistinct), among others
have garnered around the world
suggest that maybe the world
is finally catching up with
professor Muzita decades later.
She has certainly been recognized
with numerous prizes and
honors from institutions around the world
for her achievements.
And again, we are so grateful
to have her back here at Yale.
Her lecture today is titled,
women writers and the discourse
of the postwar in Japan.
Please join with me in
welcoming professor Muzita.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much, Dr. Botsman
for your very kind introduction
and also ultra kind
introduction to my sons.
Thank you very much.
I am very honored and
grateful to be invited
to deliver a lecture at
the John Hall lecture
at the Yale University.
Before so many distinguished
scholars of Japanese studies
and in other field.
It is truly a joy to have an opportunity
to come back to this campus.
As Dr. Botsman mentioned very kindly,
that as a graduate student
at the Yale university,
I lived in New Haven from 1961 to 1966.
And my stay at Yale university
had a very important meaning
for my life because it marked
nothing but the beginning
of my second life as I scholarly career.
But also I married here and
gave a birth to my first son,
AKI, who is here in New Haven.
So it was a start of my family life,
and my experiences as a woman,
being married and having children,
and then their children
started in New Haven here.
Also the time I came here
in 1961 was that time when,
and then until 1966,
it's the time when United States
went through very radical changes
in society and in culture.
I will never forget one
day coming out of my class
and quitting the Hall of graduate studies
and walking on the street
and on the television,
I heard the announcement
of the assassination
of President John F. Kennedy.
And the assassination of
the president underscores
the tension that was
really becoming very acute
in the world.
And Cuba had undergone a
very successful revolution,
but suddenly Cuba was thrust
into the middle of the tension
of the cold war between the
United States and Soviet Union.
So the threat of the nuclear
war was felt very palpable.
During that time, particularly in 1961
was the time of the beginning
of the civil rights movement.
And of course it grew to during the 1960s
and then into seventies,
but 1961 was really
the start when students
and people started being
involved in the movement
and particularly school
students were on the forefront
of that movement.
I remember very clearly in 1964,
my husband and my infant son,
we joined the March to
Washington in 1964 to hear
the Dublin Arthur Martin
Luther King speak.
And I was very much thrilled
that the historical changes
it's taking place before last.
And that period also was the very dynamic
and then active cultural
changes in the United States.
And in granite village,
we could hear beatnik read
poetry and off Broadway theater
was very active, introducing
to American audience
many very radical works
such as the blacks,
and then Maad by Asad and
also the music free jazz
and so forth, gave me a feel that really
the dynamism of cultural changes,
and then also the sense of freedom
that is really taking
place in the United States.
I remember being very moved,
seeing John by singing
barefoot in the night club.
And that was really a wonderful time.
One of the events that I will
not forget that I experienced
during my stay in Yale was that
one of my very close friends
Taun (indistinct), who was
introduced by Dr. Botsman
just now, came to Yale to do her readings.
And I organized the reading
because I knew how well in Japan
and also her books, her
poems were translated
and then had a very, not a very large,
but a good audience in
English speaking people.
And the person who came
with her as a translator
was Kate (indistinct).
And you all know Kate's
(indistinct) work sexual politics,
which now is considered the
classic of the feminist literature.
But at that time she was
professor of English literature
at Barnard,
and it was before she transformed herself
into a very radical feminist.
So it was a very interesting event for me,
knowing Kate (indistinct) as a person
who was really writing,
being engaged in writing that volume book,
the feminist criticism
of English literature.
Now, I came to Yale
university in order to study
William Forkner because at
the time the Yale university
had so many really
young group of scholars,
and I was very much excited to meet
and take courses of wonderful professors,
including Woodward and Robert Ben Warren,
and then W.H Jordan and then
John Holland among others.
And I went to consult professor
Cray Brooks about writing
dissertation on folk, but
Dr. Crat Brooks mentions that
he just wrote a authoritative
book on William Forkner
and there's nothing left for me to say,
nor any scholars to say about Forkner.
And instead he introduced, I mean,
he suggested that I do
research on Edgar Allen Poe
because he was very much under estimated
at the time in 1961,
no new books were written on Poe.
And I was very, very
grateful for his suggestions
because it was really
the start of my research
scholarly research on Edgar Poe,
who has a tremendous influence
on Japanese literature,
through (indistinct) and so
forth, the French symbolist.
And also this was the first
encounter of a real prototype
of outcast in literature.
And then this theme of outcast
and in Japanese (indistinct),
has remained one of the central
themes of literary research.
Now coming out of Japan,
being born in 1930s
and myself went through
the period of (indistinct)
Japanese and Pacific war.
When I was a child, the
war was over when I was a
third grade in the elementary school.
And I went through my junior
high dates after the war,
during the occupations.
And that was a time in Japan
suffered from the lack of food.
And even the starvation went through
and Japan was under the occupation
of the allied United
allied army based in Tokyo.
And then (indistinct)
was fixed in order to
support Japan's economic development.
So it was $360 per Yen
and Japanese to take only $200 a year.
So it was really a tremendous
experience as a young woman
to be out of Japan,
which was really confined in
its own territory and its own
thinking to come to Yale
and see now many, you know,
the young people who really
enjoy freedom of activities and
then thought in those days.
But at the time I came,
Yale was attended exclusively by men.
So sure enough, I did not see
any female student on campus,
and also in graduate seminars,
women formed the minority,
for sure, but inherent had hall,
which was at that time I was
assign that's the graduate of
women's dormitory, there
are so many foreign women,
young scholars from all over
the world and then global
community was formed there.
And it was the first time for
me to meet Korean women or
Chinese women who are from
the neighboring countries,
but we Japanese didn't have any
chance to be in contact with
the people from the world.
And I do remember very clearly
those days that United States
was inviting many young
scholars to, you know,
its own country with are
very generous scholarships
and also urged young people to go abroad
and to see the world,
for example, as a part of
the peace Corps, a group.
So it was really the start of
the globalized of education
of thinking and then
the personal exchanges.
And that was really a wonderful time.
And I was very grateful that
I had an opportunity to study
at the Yale university in those days.
I would like to move on to
the theme of my talk today.
That is about single law.
It means that postwar discourse
and postwar Japan discourse, and well,
since the start of the
end of the war in 1945 on,
Japanese had been debating
and then furiously,
even fighting in the
understanding of the postwar, Japan,
in many terms in political and social
and then cultural terms,
and that are really occupied field of
philosophy and thinking,
and then criticism in Japan,
and then still now it goes on
and many people think that the postwar,
a period of Japan has not ended
and still will not be over
in the foreseeable near future.
And simply because we
now in 2022 face a very
serious challenge from the name
laboring countries in Asia,
from Korea, from China and
then east Asian countries,
Southeastern countries,
which were colonized or invaded
by Japan and particularly
the question of forced to
label and the comfort women
are the very, very hot
and then serious issues
right now in 2022, after almost 80 years
of the end of the war,
and also the question of the
existence of the American army
base in Okinawa, as you know,
court is so much also the
problems and then also the debate
among Japanese people,
which divided their thinking of Japanese.
And then the direction is
coming this soon and the upper
house of Japanese (indistinct)
and that protest issue
most important issue is the
change of the constitution,
which many Japanese
think that it was imposed
by the United States.
And it was not the choice,
the own choice of Japanese
people to have this constitution,
which assures the peace,
a peaceful nation,
and also the gender equality for women.
So even though many
years have passed this,
we still debate that those
problems which are caused
by the second world war and
probably goes back much before
are not solved unless
we face these problems
and come up with very
reasonable solutions.
Then young people cannot go
ahead to think of the future
as a member of the Japan,
as a national entity.
So the post war period can be
considered in different ways.
One of the ways to refer to
this period is since 1945,
that Japan surrendered to
the Western countries and,
to 1952, when the occupied
allied occupation was over,
that is suddenly the very
immediate since the concrete,
since the possible period.
But most of us, as I
have mentioned just now,
I think that the postwar
continues to go on in 1960s when
Japan experienced a
very (indistinct) rapid
economic development with
some environmental problems
caused by this economic development.
And also into 1970s when
Yen started floating.
And then the foreign exchange
rate became the subject
of competition in the market
of the foreign exchange.
And Japan became economically
independent in the sense that,
that this protected rates of
exchange is now is thrown away.
And then oil shock came.
And then after that Japan
experienced this bubble
economic development in 1980s.
And then in 1990s,
we had a very shocking
event caused by (indistinct)
this setting attack on the
people of Japan in subway.
And these many critics and
then I think as in Japan,
consider that those instant mark,
the end of the post war
period, but nevertheless,
from the start of 21st century,
those problems are not,
I mean, the problems caused by the,
the invasion of Japan and the
colonization of the countries
around Japan were not solved.
And as I mentioned that the
comfort women problems really
and important, important issues
that we cannot just ignore
and forget about it and then go on
living in the modern period and
also this question of atomic
bomb and then radiations,
and then the damage that it
gives to human body and so forth
has never been nearly faced
directory as a problem of Japan
and also as a problem
of the United States,
I think which justified its use
to end the war and then to as say,
very controlled of the world
with the democratic thinking.
So I agree with these
critics who really think
it's important for us to
solve these problems in order
to end the postwar discussive
conditions in Japan.
Let me just summarize the
point of the postwar discourse
that were developed in these 80 years,
almost 80 years in the post world war.
One is the question of the responsibility
and the paying of the
deportation to those nations
which are colonized and to
those people who are victimized
during the war,
and many people think it
has no been done properly.
And still there are so many
people who are left and then who
are very silent about this
being victimized by the war.
And of course, that comfort
women and then forced labor
is really at the core of the issue.
And the second point of the
discourse of the post war Japan,
it's the insistence of the
particularity of Japanese
as Japanese people and also
the mentality, the culture,
a cultural tradition of Japan.
So the (indistinct) as we call
it, which we had the book,
the very in influential
book by (indistinct),
the Human Debations in the
Vertical Society, (indistinct).
And also a book anatomy
of dependence (indistinct)
by (indistinct) and there
other works written by Kaha.
And they really talk about a
very uniqueness of Japanese
mentality in Japanese culture,
which are not so easily destroyed
by the occupation of the
United States or the defeat of the war.
It has a much deep rooted
the basis origins that Japan
built up during the long period
of its own development.
And together with this
particularity of Japanese mentality
and Japanese culture,
people started deceiving the
kind of criticism of this
particularity by say, the
Korean Japanese writers that
the particularities and then a
uniqueness are not on genuine
qualities, but were based on
the victimization of the others
who do not belong in Japanese culture.
And also the point of this
discussion is occupied by
so called (indistinct),
that twisted the phenomenon
of a Japanese really mind
and particularly very evident
in the post war period.
And the important debate that
are developed between (indistinct)
the view of this (indistinct) very clearly
that Yomo thinks that fear is responsible
for those who are killed in
the war, in that as a survivor,
of this tremendous Imperial regime
that led Japan into the war and victimized
many young people.
And he grew up as a young man
believing in this ideology
and was ready to face his
death and to feel very guilty
about what he went through as a young man.
So he tries to go into the
analysis of a very complete
analysis of what led Japan to
have this extra ordinary act
of getting into the second
world war and the forced Japan
into the competition of the
colonial politics of the world.
On the other hand,
(indistinct), as you all know,
are very ashamed of the Japan's defeat.
The (indistinct) was
not very much affected
by the war itself, but
the defeat of the war,
the concept of the defeat somehow,
which was very alien
to Japanese tradition.
And then also as a nation that
destroyed the identity and
the pride of Japanese people.
(indistinct) Could not take
the young generations of Japan
who really enjoy economic development
and then new freedom that
was just forced by the
United States to make Japan a
perfect ally that will support
the Americas and the birds
in the international society
as a nation which does not have
the force to defend itself.
Another important debate was
also developed by Yomo Yoki
and (indistinct) probably who
are familiar with Japanese
literally criticism
will know (indistinct).
He's a very important
critic in the field of
literally criticism.
He was born in 1930s and my generation
he's a few years older than I am,
but came to the United
States and stayed at the age
actually, I mean, he came
to study at Princeton,
but I met him at the Yale
university at the time of the
lecture delivered by Donald
King and his point of net day,
phenomenal of Japanese
mentality, stem from two factors.
One is the unconditional surrender.
This concept of unconditional
surrender is also
the subject of debate, but
he thinks Japan gave up
all of its identity to
the concept of democracy.
And also the concept of the United States,
the political endeavor in
making of the power areas
to support the America.
And so Japan was deprived of
the force armed forever to
defend itself and also to
depend upon American military
power.
And the other point is that
occupation by the American force
and the perfect censorship
that controlled the development
of postwar Japanese culture,
and then thinking that
created Japanese mentalities,
not to speak out very
freely against the politic,
I mean that and discuss
the political factors,
but we go into the very
under stated and very twisted
the argument in talking about
the post war Japanese society
and the culture.
And he talks about the
crime of fatherhood,
the power of the father, and
then also of the motherhood,
which was considered to be all embracing
the power close to nature,
and then lacking the
subjective desire as agenda.
And he comes up with the
conclusions that the most important
thing for post war Japan
should daily regain the pride
and identity in the power of fatherhood,
which is directly related
to the nation itself.
And the third point of the,
the postwar discourse,
it's something to do
with what we called cultural topography,
that it concerns the memories
of the ruins and defeat
and the memories of the
disaster of the nation
that underwent the defeat and changes,
not in a very obvious political thousand,
but I say talking about the
cultural sites such as American
army base and the black market
that really appeared in the,
the complete (indistinct)
the doings in Tokyo,
the 70% of Tokyo was completely
destroyed by the early aids,
but it concerned with the memories,
how Japan will maintain
the memory of this defeat
and destruction and in the
development of Japanese
cities and then Japan as a nation.
So it goes very deeply into
the layers of memories,
the memories of disaster
in the earthquakes,
and then all these things
layer by layer that
the calamities and
disaster Japan experienced
and particularly in the post war period.
And the first point about the,
this course of the postwar
of Japan is to praise Japan's
postwar situations in an
international and comparative
perspectives, particularly
the cold war world.
So instead of calling postwar,
they were called cold war.
That is of course the overlaps,
the period of post war because the,
the cold war situation
started immediately after
the cold war.
And the thoughts, people
who argue that changing,,
shifting the perspectives
of talking of the post war,
in Japan (indistinct) it in
the world situation of
postcolonialism and then post war.
And those arguments were
read by (indistinct),
a very well known feminist.
Like now it's very active
and also (indistinct),
the younger generations
who did not experience
the second world war as a childhood.
Most of the critics and the
thinkers who were involved
in post war, Japanese
discourse are to consider that
the post wars situations
are present at this time
and the Japanese conservative
political parties,
and the many conservative,
the writing people try to
forget about this defeat
experiences and what happened in the war,
and to build up Japan as an
truly independent nations with a
military force and probably
empowering Japanese army force
and the Japanese nation to
cope with the international
threat that is really
taking place in 2022.
And although I agree with those critics,
that the post war situation
was never be over,
but for different reasons.
And what is very
important is that in all these
discourse on post war Japan,
clearly the women's
experiences of the post war,
it was that the women themselves
went through a tremendous
change caused by the war, has
not been discussed at all,
almost at all.
And also that the perspective
of gender is absent
in most of, or almost all of the critics
who talked about and
discussed the post war, Japan.
And it did not mean that
Japanese women did not think
during the, you know, all these 80 years,
but women did express
their own understanding
of the post war Japan and so forth,
but they are really put
into a special field
of feminist criticism,
dealing with the women's issue
and were not integrated into
the overall discourse on post war Japan.
They were the women problems
and the men do not understand
their problems because they are not women.
So although the very active
discussion was taking
place in the world war years,
they were treated as a special
kind of discussions that are
relevant only to women, but
not for the nation as a whole.
So the result is that we
still having gender divisions,
the Japanese women are very
much kept away from taking part
in the very political important areas,
which makes decisions
about gender comfort.
Women problems are not
solved and so forth.
And one other absence
of perspective is that
although the critics are involved
in the post war discourse,
very much writers and poets
and the scholars of literature,
and then critics, they did
not deal with the works itself
in order to see how the world changed,
how the conscious has changed,
what are the problems
that affected our lives
and then mentality after
the war caused by this,
the radical change and
the defeat and destruction
that Japan met probably for
the first time in it's history.
Thank you very much, I'm sorry.
So the purpose here for my lecture is that
to examine what women
writers thought and discussed
in the next phrase as their understanding
of the postwar experiences and how this
absence of women's writers work had made
the discourse debate on the postwar period
made kind of oriented
discussions centered around,
say the politics and the
nations in the world.
And I like to
analyze probably three poets
and the two novelist here
if I have enough time and
if allowed to discuss them.
There are so many women
writers and actually what the
characterize is the post war
literally phenomena is the,
the lives of women writers,
the brilliant writers,
and you cannot ignore
the works of those writers
when you discuss, and then,
you know, analyze the
modern Japanese literature.
The first poet that I like
to mention is (indistinct),
who wrote a very in
influential book in 1963
and was made and the published
as a book form in 1965,
which is entitled "The Third
Six," that immediately,
I think you are reminded of
the Second Six by (indistinct).
And that is of course,
that marks the start of the
post to all feminist thinking
in the Western world.
The third sex seems to be more
advanced than the second sex.
Anyhow, she's talking about the
division of female sexuality
between the categories of
women who bear children,
who don't bear children.
That is a disparity that was
caused by the patriarchal
family system about the
norm of heterosexual,
the relationship of gender.
And she develops the ideas
into the third possibilities
of that choice that sexuality
should not be divided
into two categories,
but there is a multiple
possibilities for women's sexuality
beyond this division of child
birth and then the maternity.
And this is a, a very, very,
a kind of stimulating discussion
that took place in 1965,
she was born in Korea and
repatriated in the post war Japan.
So her experiences of
being brought up in Korea,
I think was a very unique
aspect of the postwar thinking.
And she also dealt with the (indistinct),
the making of a prostitute
at the very early stage
of the discussion of the comfort women.
And then I like to mention
Stacey (indistinct) as a poet
who is also born in the so-called
outside territory of Japan
Gache, but in her case,
she was born in Vancouver
and came back to Japan
just before the end of the war.
Although she was very much, I think,
read by Japanese audience
and also her works are
translated in the United
States, in English and so forth.
She was considered as a black
sheep and then considered as
(indistinct), outcast
also through her life,
as a woman, as a poet,
and as anything that you can think about.
And she was very proactive
in approaching American base,
which is a new topic that
appeared for the first time
after the war and still goes on
and then subject of the discussion.
And then she had a very,
what I call the taboo subject
of having sexual relations
with outsiders, the black
servicemen and then so forth,
and then thought about the
sexual freedom of Japanese women,
which somehow undermines the
federal sexual normative.
The concept of the sexuality
of patriarchal family system
that pushed, I mean,
forced the women's sexuality to be
in the child bearing
sexuality and also motherhood.
And she has a very striking
poem called My Tokyo,
that is situated in the
postwar period of Japan,
that subterranean territory
of Tokyo, the subway systems,
which really it's
developed very extensively,
starting from the end of the war as the,
the metaphor for female body.
And so the outcasts
and then devolutionist,
and then foreigners go
through the women's bodies
that really the most of the territories,
the subterranean territories of Tokyo,
which has been rebuilt and
then modernized very quickly
in the post war areas.
And so she kind of
deconstruct the motherhood,
not as a child bearing sexuality, but also
a kind of (indistinct) and a place where
embraces the death and the
life of those who are hurt
by the damage caused by the war
and also who do not have the
place to live within the system
that is established.
And also her contemporary
(indistinct), also
the author of the very
important poem of the postwar,
Japanese modern poetry,
and also the translator
of Sylvia (indistinct).
She talks of the absence of fatherhood,
the God and the existence
which really determines
the norms of the human
existence and also sexual norms
and so forth.
But in other sense,
what she calls a radical
evil that takes place
and this concept of radical
evil is taken, I think
from the (indistinct) concept of Narcism
that there is an absolute evil
which causes this destruction
and then the violence
in the world, but we
don't know what it is.
It's the kind of chaos that is displaced
in the place which hitherto
fatherhood and the national,
the identity had occupied.
And hers stories of the poems
are very much concentrated on
her mother's experiences as
a free new women in 1920s.
That the time of (indistinct), the very
active feminist movement of 1920s
through the genre called the (indistinct).
But those are experiences of new women
had to face the complete
defeat and the failure
because of the rights of
the Imperial power in Japan.
And then (indistinct) is
one of those women who
thought the freedom of female sexuality
and then subjectivity through
the extra marital relationship
sexual relationship,
but had the experience of
being betrayed by that desire.
And in the postwar, a period of Japan,
she was protected by her legal husband
together with the daughter of
the extra marital relationship
protected by the nuclear family system,
which is also the system,
the much smaller form of
patriarchal family system,
but also the system which
is based at the foundation
of Japanese new economic
development after the war,
placing Japan and women to a very definite
sexual world as a housewife
who is in charge of the,
the production of the labor
force and then the life.
So (indistinct) experience
and then expression of
her postwar feeling is how
to deal with this tremendous
failure of the feminist
women who were active
and had a hope for human
female subjectivity in 1920s,
and have been completely
pushed to oblivion
and also to oppressions after the war.
So she tried to take a over
the heritage of these new women
in the beginning of the 20th
century, but at the same time,
a kind of desire to
transcend the heterosexual
relations and also the marriage
that created as the basis
of the modern Japan.
So her words that,
it was very violent in the sense that
she talks of the pain and
agony that women's body,
female body took as the burden
of all the victimizations
of the post war period.
But then she talks very positively
about the multi diversity
of human, I mean, female sexuality
that it's completely hidden
in the post war of Japan.
And the third novelist, and
the person I'd like to mention
is (indistinct), who also
stayed in Alaska for 12 years.
Alaska above all other places
that didn't know the area
not of the United States,
but of the earth where
the outcast, you know,
come to live from all over the world.
As a wife of the businessman
who went to say, get lumbers
and then, you know,
they make paper pulses for
the development of Japanese
economy in the post war period,
but she made that debut,
the very shocking debut
as she was called in
1960s, in 1967 or something
with the work called, the three clubs.
And she has a book,
which professor Botsman
had mentioned in the,
the kind introduction has a work called,
"The Smiles of the Mountain Witch"
that analyzes the mentality
of housewives that
is very much divided into the two aspect.
One is that enjoying the protection
and then support of the family.
And then as a housewife
protected my men's economic power
and enjoys the safety
and has an environment
to raise children but the same time,
the Japanese housewives
aspire to a mountain witch,
and a mountain witch is (indistinct),
it's a very legendary
existence in Japanese folklore
and literature, that transcends
the norms of sexuality.
Sometimes she's very violent,
she's aggressive, but at the same time,
she's free from all the
jurisdictions of the communities.
And then probably the nation
and very free from the sexual norms.
This concept we remember
was very much developed
by other Japanese women writers,
such as (indistinct), talks
about as (indistinct) member,
as a prototype of women's independence
in the post war period.
But the most important
work that appeared in 1955
is Reshma (indistinct) novel.
The Reshma Saw is the name of the plant,
which is an endangered species,
and it actually exists.
It's a very groomy, the flower,
but you all know the Reshma legend
that like the (indistinct)
in Western counterpart,
Reshma spent a few years in
the under sea, the paradise,
and then coming back to his
homeland, he discovers that,
that the Homeland was
changed almost completely
the not races of former community
and the existence in the
country itself disappeared.
So he opens up the
(indistinct), a jewelry box,
which was given by the
queen of that under world.
Opens up the (indistinct)
and the smoke comes out
and it just
let all his memories of the
homeland in the past life
go away and then disappear.
The story of Reshma Saw is a story about
a young woman, Japanese woman
who came back from the United
States after her studies
in United States together
with her boyfriend
who was thinking of marriage in Japan.
And she comes to live
with her half brother,
whose name is (indistinct)
and a mountain man in a house,
which is in the peripheral of Tokyo,
together with his lover,
who has a child that,
who is autistic and mute without speech.
And Roko his lover's husband,
who just came back from the war front.
And then this (indistinct)
has an adopted daughter
who is born probably
of the American father
and who takes care of
this mute autistic child.
So it's a very strange community,
existing form of one
family, the lover and,
and her husband,
and then the child who was born out of
Hiroshima experiences.
Roko went to Hiroshima soon after the war
and there he met Morita,
her lover, and had a child.
So the child becomes a
symbol of the atomic weapon
and then effect of the radiation
on not only the human body,
but at the same time, the
Japanese society in general.
So it's a very strange family,
the community that symbolizes
the effect of the atomic bomb.
And (indistinct) point is that
we cannot think of going back
to the pre-atomic weapon age,
or no, the culture or the country,
the atomic bomb experience
is so definite and so serious
that it changes completely not
just the community tradition,
but also the Japanese
mentalities psychology,
but also the entire world
that we have to really face
the effect of atomic bomb, its damages
it gives to not only human bodies,
but the entire life of us.
At the end of the story,
it's that this (indistinct)
young man who studied
in the United States
decides not to get married
to an American young man.
And goes back to the United
States as an independent woman
to continue her study
in the United States.
And (indistinct) the adopted daughter
who takes care of the mute child,
decides to have a baby
with that child who was
really a kind of symbolic existence
of the effect of the atomic weapon.
And thus over said that we should really
kind of accept the heritage of
atomic damage and sufferings
by having a baby from that mute child.
But at the same time that we
have to face the irreversible
conditions that atomic bomb created
on everything on the earth.
So she goes back to the
United States accepting
probably the presence of
America in the post war,
Japan and in the post war
world as an independent woman.
So accept this (indistinct) as it is.
And then the future of Japan,
the future of the world is
placed on that new child
who will be born out of
this autistic mute child.
And then over asks the question,
what about the Reshma legend
that the smoke comes out
as an atomic, you know,
smoke and the tremendous,
the mushroom cloud that
covers up the whole world,
and then it's postwar Japan
going to be completely erased
as the important existence
in the postwar, the world.
And Japan is going to forget
this agonizing experiences
just by the militarizing the nations,
and to have an probably
atomic weapon in the future.
Then what about this experiences
of the humankind of having
invented this terrible destructive weapon?
And now the world is getting
into the conflict among nations
who try to develop its power,
the political military power
by creating more advanced
nuclear weapons.
So she kind of parallels the
experience of the atomic bomb,
that it is so decisive in
determining the human mentality
and human culture through
female experience of having
her body affected and
having the children affected
and so forth.
But world is going to forget as if it is
covered by the smoke, you know,
which came out of the
(indistinct) jewelry box
and into the oblivion.
So it's the most think strong,
the questions that are put to the
the people of the post
war world, not just Japan,
but the countries,
which really forget about the tragedies of
the use of the atomic weapons,
but they are very, very
serious about strengthening
this terrible weapons in
order to fortify their power,
ihe military powers in the 21st centuries.
So I like to end my
discussion of this discourse
on the postwar by talking
about (indistinct),
who is, again, one of the
very important writers
who criticized the middle class family,
and particularly women and
men who enjoyed very much
so-called middle class
development together with the
technological development
and an economic power
that really created
the modern Japanese state
and economic affluence
in the postwar period.
And she talks about this forecast,
I mean, not forecast outcast
of this modern society itself
together with the concept
of mountain witches
and then so forth, who will not have
the subjectivity presented
in the post war period.
So far as Japan will not face this sexual
discrimination, the violence,
and then gender divisions,
which are covered up as
so much by the will free
by the government.
And then also by people
who just don't want to face
this phenomena.
And also so far as Japan and
the world come up to face with
the risk that tremendous risk,
that atomic weapon in
the use of the radiation.
And in that means electric
power plant and power
the reactor that of
course is very dangerous
to the human life.
Not only the human life
to the environment,
that 3.11 of the post, I mean, Hiroshima
showed to us very clearly.
So these are the questions
have not been faced not only
by Japan, post war Japan,
but by the world at large,
that no one had really learned
the experiences of the,
the damage and destruction
that were caused by
the use of this nuclear weapons.
So the discussions about
the post war, Japan,
Japanese experiences, or
getting away from the Imperial
very the controlling power of the nation
into the democratic nation so-called,
but this democracy is
not really a democracy
which gives the benefit
piece and then coexistence
among those competing nations,
particularly the nations
which compete with the
fortification of the brutal,
the destructive powers.
So (indistinct) you know,
died some years ago,
but still this (indistinct) remains
as one of the representative novel
that the postwar, both political,
and also the cultural
situations that the world
must have faced very clearly,
but avoided to come to talk
about this, to think about this.
Finally, I'd like to talk
about a dear friend of mine,
who shared my own experiences of staying
in the United States at the age in 1960s,
they are (indistinct)
right now, very influential
critic and philosopher,
and his deceased wife,
the novelist (indistinct).
The (indistinct) wrote
that a very feminist,
very attractive novel called,
"The Glimpses of a Woman"
(speaking foreign language).
Which is based on (indistinct),
the story of a woman
who tries to as search
for the freedom of women,
the sexual freedom coming
to the United States.
And that was written before the war.
And so (indistinct) was
staying at New Haven at Yale
together with her husband
that came to rethink of this
female kind of imagination,
and then such into real freedom
in the democratic societies.
And again, coming to the United States,
just as the hearings of the (indistinct)
came to the United States in search of it
and face in the United
States, in her search,
and then (indistinct)
has the same experiences
and has this version
of other (indistinct),
if you are interested in that was,
you know, I'd like you to read that work,
which came out of her
experiences at Yale University,
and then (indistinct).
His latest works are very
much common in his ideas of
criticizing the state nations that emerged
after Imperial in nation.
The modern nation state
is the betrayal of the hope for the future
in the post war world.
And he presents the
prototype of mountain man,
which is the counterpart
of mountain witches
who live outside of this
jurisdiction, of the community.
The very strong community
probably linked very directly
to the nationalism of the nation's state.
And then he envision the community,
which is free from the
political control and the power,
the community which is
created by free exchange
and then distribution of the wealth.
So I think right now,
somehow mountain man and mountain witches
came to meet together in a
new, probably development
of the postwar, Japanese discourse,
and remembering these
friends who really shared
the experiences of staying
at the age in 1960s.
It seemed to be very far
away, but at the same time,
the experiences still, I think,
bring us are not the facing the programs
caused by the second world war.
I feel very happy to be back and then
to have been given this opportunity
to come back to the Yale campus.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- We have microphones for the audience,
which we can run out.
So however you'd like
to call the questions?
- Yes, yes, yes, please.
- The floor is open to
questions or comments.
- Thank you very much for
your extraordinary lecture.
I'm Edward Kamens, we met many years ago.
When you interviewed me for
a job, which I didn't get.
(audience laughing)
A young fellow named (indistinct)
got that job, I believe.
- Yes, of course.
- But it's such an honor to
have you return to our campus.
I was so fascinated by your
discussion of the cultural,
topography of defeat.
The (indistinct), the burned out city,
the remnants of the black markets
and the military installations.
Could you tell us if any of the writers
that you spoke about or others have had
a special relationship
or made special use of
that topography in scenes
represented in their poetry
or their novels or short stories?
- Yes.
Thank you very much for your question.
I think that we talk about
the critics of this culture
topography, the first
person who came to my mind
is (indistinct), who looked at
the postwar, the topography.
I mean, the scenery of Tokyo
was completely destroyed
and changed the construction of the city,
unlike say that of Germany
and Poland and so forth.
Try to rebuild the same kind of building,
same kind of communities,
same the Plaza and so forth.
Japan just forgot about the,
the post war structures
and then built up a new,
the buildings, high-rise
buildings, and then so forth.
They tried to create
new the city synergies.
But the question of
memories that topography
and then scenery are very
much related to the memories.
Once the scenery changes,
we also forget about the memories
and then things, the lives
and the culture that existed
in the former scenery
just disappear.
But like in Kyoto,
you see that there are layers
of these conflicts among the
families, and then all these
complicated memories are,
you know, accumulated.
And so the critics such as (indistinct),
try to deal with the memories.
Very important I think there the concept
of our human experiences in history
that we tend to forget, but don't forget.
And that creates more
the psychological, again,
the twist in the development
of the new world.
But if you look at the works,
literally works that you
can find lots of them
as an important topics in
(indistinct) and then all these,
that (indistinct) who experienced
the logical distractions
and I myself, you know,
was born and lived in Japan as a child,
but I can't find any
remnant of my childhood life
after the war because the
destruction was so complete.
And so the airways just, you know,
let everything disappear in one night,
but the memory ring us
and what is very important
is the memories, how we keep the memories,
how we make a new hope
and then development
out of digesting these memories
and not forgetting about it.
And I think these other coaches' work
was very in influential I think,
that was written in late 1960s
in the (indistinct) period
and this black market also
is a very interesting topics,
I think, it developed into
the golden eye of (indistinct)
and all these special, you know,
the sections of Zakaya and
so forth came out of the
black market areas and also
it's the area where foreigners,
people who came back
from the colonial Korea
and so forth, came there and
then had their own business
that developed into the big
business of (indistinct)
and then others and in the
development of the economics
prosperity in Japan.
So it is very new,
but refreshing way of talking
about the post war phenomena
and culture, not just always talking about
the political issues of the government,
criticizing how the
government had a long policy
and so forth, but look at the topos
that we built our post war life.
- [Chloe] Thank you very much, Chloe Star.
Do you think your women writers,
reformulations of female
sexuality had any effect on
male writers or men more
generally in their understanding
of women's sexuality in the
period following the writing?
- Right now in Japan?
- [Chloe] I mean, in the decade
or two following, you know,
the rethinking on women as not
necessarily just childbearing
for example.
- Oh, I see, yes.
In the post war period in
Japan, it is very peculiar
I think, abnormal in a sense that
this discussion about the
society and the history
are completely limited to
male thinkers and critics
that putting all the experiences of women
and also what women thought and expressed
into a big parenthesis
that it is women's issues.
And then it's the discuss
on feminist criticism
and analysis, and that did not
exist, I think in the world,
like since 1960s, France
has been dealing with these
feminist issues and then the sexual norms,
and then so forth very much
into the discussion integrated
part of the thinking of the new world,
but Japan somehow completing ignored.
I think it is a question of the criticism,
the critics in Japan,
that they really thought
they can get away with
facing these issues and then questions.
And I think it would
have been very different.
And also talking about female
expressions, representations too,
I think we have a different
images of post war period.
And I think we could have
imagined differently much earlier
if we talked about female experiences,
how they accepted and
tried to transcend this
really very agonizing
experience of new women,
the phenomena of (indistinct) period
and how the female body was controlled
by the political, you know,
the policies during the war
and so forth.
We should have discussed material
and faced those questions,
I think.
- I had two questions.
One, is really a clarification.
I wondered, so am I correct in thinking
that you were presenting
(indistinct) as a critique
of the (indistinct)
position on (indistinct)?
So rather than trying
to fix the (indistinct)
we should accept it and
see what comes out of that.
Is that the correct way to think about it?
- Well, very it's very
much the post discourse.
It's based on how to accept the
United States, it's policies
and then in forming democratic nations
with this peace constitution and so forth,
it's divided in a radical
way that probably like doing
people deject dependency on
the United States in America.
And then others think that
despite the fact that,
that we do did experience
and occupation areas,
which was very much
controlled by the censorship,
nevertheless, it was
a good thing for Japan
that it came out of this
military control Imperial
at the power into a new possibilities
of the democratic develop.
It's very much divided.
But when you look at
the phenomenon through
the women's perspective, the
things look very different.
I mean, the existence of
America became, I mean,
symbolically and not just
the outsiders or insider,
but it became very complicated
part of the post war Japan
development and it's
also have a sexual too,
in a way that (indistinct) present
that the boy who was born is
taken care of by a daughter
who was born of American,
probably the soldiers or whatever.
And then as a symbol
of atomic bomb damage,
but then has to be really
accepted and then to have a new
baby out of the symbol
of the atomic weapon,
that's the only start of our overcoming,
this (indistinct) post war phenomenon.
So she's positive at the
same time, very critical
and rejecting this discourse
developed by made critics,
I think in general.
- Thank you.
The second question if I may is,
so you spoke a lot about
the need to overcome
the question of atomic
war and atomic weapons.
And I wondered not to
speak on behalf of people
who are younger,
but my sense today is that
the question of climate change
and the anthropocene has
somehow dwarfed the question
of nuclear war.
So the nuclear question has now become one
that is a kind of subset
of this bigger problem,
both of which basically
spelled the possibility
of the end of the world as we know it.
But I wonder how you think
about that problem and those two
things in relation to each
other, particularly given that,
whereas Japan has had
the unique experience of
being bombed by atomic weapons,
the question of climate change,
and this bigger question of
the destruction of the world
is one that really is universal
in a very different way.
So I wonder if you have
any thoughts about those?
- Well, I think that my
experiences in the United States,
in 1960s is that I was
really struck by the fact
most of the American justifies
the use of the atomic bomb,
that it is a method to end the war,
and also even to save Japanese
from a mass (indistinct).
And it was a unbelievable
for those who witnessed
the real damage of the nuclear weapon.
It's really very brutal and
unbelievably, just, you know,
unbelievable agony was
put to human beings.
And also it's very much
related to the, you know,
the parts of the children.
We know the effect of
the radio activities.
It's very serious for our, you know,
the futility and the strategy,
and then so and so forth.
And it also stays on in
the earth in the water,
and circulate to damage the earth.
It is one of the most serious,
you know, experiences we
had during the war, I think,
but to look at the world right now,
no one is seriously
discussing the control of
the atomic weapon and so forth.
But I think from the
environmental standpoint of view,
I think younger generation
will come to understand
that if you use the nuclear power,
you will have to deal
with the tremendous waste.
And it's a gummy garbage
that not only the earth
but the universe has to deal with.
And it is such a most uneconomical
and futuristic attempt
to use the electricity
for the immediate purpose of development.
People say we need it, the electricity.
It's very essential, but to
use even the nuclear reactor.
And then of course we face
the danger of Ukrainian.
You know, the conflict,
even though the nuclear
reactor is not used,
still it is bombed.
Then all the radioactivities will come out
and then damage the
earth almost permanently.
And that is a kind of the
heritage that the second world war
left to us and we have
to face it, I think.
I very strongly believe
that this kind of waste
that the human development
or happiness or whatever,
the convenience and so forth,
it's really the boomerang
that will come back to us
and then we have to do something about it.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much
everybody (indistinct).
And thank Professor Mizuta (indistinct).
- Thank you very much.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)